[Música]
ucrania acusa a rusia de recurrir a lo
que llama tácticas terroristas con
misiles y dice que están bombardeando
líneas de suministro de armamento uno de
los ataques más fuertes es en la acería
de mariupol ampliaremos desde ucrania
y como consecuencia de la guerra en el
este europeo los precios aumentan en
todo el mundo en méxico el presidente de
andrés manuel lópez obrador se unió con
más de 30 empresas en un plan para
combatir la inflación tenemos
información desde ciudad de mexico
y en francia se fortalece la izquierda
de cara a las legislativas de junio los
socialistas alcanzaron un principio de
acuerdo por el partido francia y sumisa
a la coalición ya se unieron los
ecologistas y los comunistas
bienvenidos a las noticias de france 24
mi nombre es maría clara calle y es un
placer saludarlos y comenzamos con la
actualidad de la guerra en ucrania rusia
anunció que atacaría las líneas de
suministro con las que la otan provee
armas a ucrania luego de esto quiere
denunció que moscú está bombardeando
estaciones de ferrocarriles y otros
objetivos de líneas de suministro por lo
que el canciller ucraniano dmitro koleva
habla de tácticas terroristas uno de los
ataques estaría en mariupol el gobierno
local afirma que la arremetida rusa
aumentó y que por primera vez atacaron
la fábrica as hostal con tanques sin
embargo moscú lo niega y dice que sólo
están repeliendo la ofensiva de los
ucranianos el alcalde de mariupol vadim
boychenko agregó que ya no tienen
comunicación con los militares y los
civiles que resisten en esta fábrica en
medio de los ataques cientos de personas
lograron evacuar de la planta
siderúrgica en mariupol según el
presidente voló dimes el skip sólo este
miércoles salieron trescientos cuarenta
y cuatro civiles muchos de los evacuados
llegaron a la vecina ciudad de sap
orilla nuestra enviada especial ángel
nos cuenta más desde allí este
parqueadero a la entrada a la ciudad de
sap orilla se ha convertido en el lugar
soñado de miles y miles de personas que
huyen de ciudades en el sur de ucrania
no sólo de mariupol donde llegaban más
de 130 personas que vivían de la ciudad
sino también de otras ciudades que están
en control de las fuerzas rusas desde
hace ya varias semanas como melitópol
libertad ese es el caso de tamara este
plan a que llegaron hoy
piqué muy pic y es difícil irse es
difícil y probablemente la mayoría de la
gente no quiera irse por eso es muy
difícil ellos los rusos podemos decirlo
de esta manera son muy abruptos
ellos exigen tarjetas sin auriculares
cigarrillos revisan los teléfonos
revisaron todas mis fotos todos los
chats de telegram y buscaban la bandera
ucraniana o cualquier cosa relacionada
con la simbología ucraniana
en este parqueadero se sigue esperando
que más personas puedan huir de esa
sería de aceptar donde cientos de
personas siguen todavía en esos refugios
subterráneos y están asediadas por esas
fuerzas rusas sin embargo poco a poco
van llegando vehículos privados de
personas que al lugar han logrado huir
de las ciudades que no lo pueden hacer
directamente tienen que ir a una ciudad
de verdad es que el poder de las fuerzas
rusas allí ir pasando cada uno de esos
retenes más de 17 del ejército ruso con
las dificultades hasta poder llegar
hasta aquí hay personas que se tardan
incluso tres o cuatro días en otras
noticias el gobierno mexicano de andrés
manuel lópez obrador se unió con más de
30 empresas para combatir la elevada
inflación la administración sostiene que
no es un control de precios sino una
serie de medidas para asegurar que por
ejemplo los alimentos tengan un precio
justo previamente desde ciudad de méxico
nuestro corresponsal mario carbonell nos
explicó en qué consiste el plan
así es
contiene varias medidas una de ellas es
precisamente mantener los precios de
gasolina y diésel que no aumentarán pero
también se aumentará en 2 millones de
toneladas la producción de granos
básicos como arroz maíz y frijol para
evitar la escasez y que no suban los
precios asimismo se aumentará de 5 a 9
estados los que recibirán apoyos de
fertilizantes para los cultivos entre
otras medidas también habrá el fijo los
precios para los peajes de las
carreteras para que no aumenten tampoco
los costos de la cadena de distribución
y se incrementará la seguridad también
en las vías de comunicación para evitar
robos y que esto también impacte en los
precios y también se aplicará una medida
de cero aranceles para los productos y
los insumos básicos de importación con
estas medidas el gobierno pretende que
los 24 productos de la canasta básica no
aumenten su precio y ayudar a los
trabajadores
y la campaña de las elecciones de medio
término en eeuu ahora tendrá un tema
central el aborto marcará estos comicios
de noviembre luego de que se filtrara el
borrador que mostraría que la corte
suprema de justicia puede anular la
sentencia roe versus wade que hace de la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo un
derecho constitucional
en varias ciudades de eeuu
los manifestantes se tomaron las calles
indignados su ira dirigida a la corte
suprema- tras la filtración del borrador
de una opinión que sugería que el órgano
judicial estaría a punto de anular el
fallo histórico de roe versus wade de
1973 que estableció el aborto como un
derecho constitucional da miedo es
devastador pero definitivamente estoy
motivada para seguir luchando y nos
aseguraremos de que el acceso al aborto
permanezca no se trata sólo del aborto
se trata del control y ahora estamos
viendo que el control se nos va y no lo
toleramos mientras estos manifestantes
luchan para que se mantengan los
derechos de las mujeres a decidir
algunos estados ya se están preparando
para una nueva era si se anulara el
fallo histórico el derecho a interrumpir
el embarazo se dejaría en manos de los
legisladores estatales y los líderes de
estados conservadores ya están listos
para convocar a sesiones legislativas
especiales para prohibir el
procedimiento si el tribunal supremo
revoca la sentencia el gobernador de
oklahoma firmó un proyecto de ley que
prohíbe el aborto después de seis
semanas coincidiendo con una ley similar
en texas gobernadores demócratas en
estados como california anunciaron
rápidamente planes para consagrar el
derecho al aborto en la ley local un
movimiento alentado por el presidente
joe bites en su administración pide a la
corte suprema que proteja el acceso al
aborto
como se atreven a decirle a una mujer lo
que puede y no puede hacer con su propio
cuerpo como se atreven a tratar de
evitar que determine su propio futuro
como se atreven a negar a las mujeres
sus derechos y libertades
el borrador no es una sentencia
definitiva por lo tanto no es seguro que
se revierta la histórica decisión a
pesar de una mayoría conservadora en la
corte suprema- una encuesta del
washington post y eivissa news encontró
que sólo el 28 por ciento de los
estadounidenses cree que la decisión de
1973 debería ser anulada
la izquierda francesa intenta unirse
para las legislativas de junio los
socialistas firmaron un principio de
acuerdo para sumarse a la coalición en
la que ya están la francia insumisa los
ecologistas y los comunistas ellos
intentan hacerle contrapeso contrapeso a
de manuel mayor en la asamblea nacional
mientras el presidente de barman su
agenda ecológica para su segundo
quinquenio de hecho ha jugado toda la
propuesta de planificación ecológica del
líder izquierdista jean-luc mélenchon
una apuesta decidida por el clima
el presidente francés emmanuel mccone
reunió este miércoles en el elíseo a una
docena de expertos en clima y cambio
climático para poner en marcha su
prometida planificación ecológica a las
puertas de su segundo quinquenio está
llamada a la comunidad científica busca
sentar las bases de su proyecto en
materia medioambiental uno de los
estandartes de su campaña electoral su
post kings el clec o límites santificó
esos lapsos es mejor que la comunidad
científica en el sentido más amplio
participe en las decisiones se implique
en la gestión administrativa ese es el
papel del consejo superior del clima
también es el rol de una comunidad
científica como la nuestra que cuando
nos llaman los políticos podamos
responder por el instinto friki con
ficción y recursos y comenzar los
cocineros macro me prometió en campaña
que convertirá a francia en la primera
gran nación libre de petróleo gas y
carbón el presidente adoptó la propuesta
de planificación ecológica de su rival
político el progresista jean luc
mélenchon quien ya firmó un pacto con
los ecologistas de cara a las elecciones
legislativas del próximo 12 y 19 de
junio a poco más de un mes de la nueva
cita con las urnas macrón prometió a que
su nuevo primer ministro se encargará
específicamente del reto climático que
enfrenta francia o podemos sentir en
este planteamiento de manuel macro no
creo la importancia que la edad ha hecho
muchas promesas en esta materia lo vimos
en marsella y ahora se trata asimismo de
cómo pasar estas promesas a la acción
concretas los próximos cinco años van a
ser esenciales en lo que respecta a la
lucha contra el calentamiento global y
el respeto de los objetivos establecidos
en la legislación está lejos de estar
conquistado y tampoco es fácil el
gobierno francés defendió hoy su apuesta
por el clima después de que el consejo
de estado le pidiera medidas más
concretas para cumplir sus compromisos
del acuerdo de parís y con esta noticia
de francia terminamos nuestra emisión
les agradecemos su sintonía y nos vemos
en una próxima ocasión
[Música]